John once told ET whirling Diana around  the dance floor was one of the greatest  moments of his life that's probably my  fondest memory the look she had on her  face when I asked her to dance she  blushed and I liked that I thought it  was very down to earth on a 1985 visit  to the White House Diana specifically  requested John's attendance at a state  dinner she had a bit of a crush on him  she was a big fan of his  now Diana's midnight blue velvet gown  from designer Victor Edelstein could be  yours it's up for auction again in 1997  just two months before her death et was  with Diana in New York as she previewed  her famous wardrobe that she was  auctioning off for charity  it is a mob scene about the princess  talked with everyone spent time with  each person back then the Travolta dress  sold for over two hundred twenty two  thousand dollars of per sale again the  gown is expected to fetch nearly four  hundred sixty thousand dollars  [Music]